welcome back texas and missouri are
suing the biden administration for
scrapping the remain in mexico policy
claiming the border surge is putting an
unprecedented burden on state and
federal resources
join me live one of the key players in
that lawsuit texas attorney general ken
paxton sir thank you for your time this
morning we appreciate it
good morning good morning so what do you
think is going to come of this what are
you hoping comes of this lawsuit
well we think this is one of the most
effective immigration policies that
trump
put in place it was actually working
very well
by forcing these people to stay in
mexico because everybody had figured out
through immigration lawyers
from america that they could come in
claim asylum even though
only about 14 percent ended up getting
asylum and then just disappear into the
country
so this policy was actually working why
joe biden decided to undo something so
successful i don't know but we really
believe
that we will win in court and that this
policy will be back in place
yeah we'll certainly continue to follow
that you know in the meantime with each
day that passes you do
wonder the threat long term how much
greater that threat is to our
communities not just along the border
but throughout the entire country
because of specifically the infiltration
of drugs that have come across the
border
well there's no doubt as the numbers
increase they're going to move out of
texas in the border states right now
we're taking the brunt of it there are
thousands of people here that weren't
here just
you know two months ago and those people
are going to start being moved around
because we don't have enough places for
them to stay and so the rest of the
country
will start seeing as time goes on
they'll start seeing the impact
of higher crime rates of covid the
transmission of covet and other diseases
and the issues with human trafficking
and drug smuggling that we're seeing are
you disappointed that the president and
vice president haven't
visited the border yet and have you
spoken to them about it
i have not spoken to them but i'm
extremely disappointed because i think
it's one of the major issues of our time
given their policy changes the impact i
would expect them to go down the border
and
start trying to understand the
implications of their of what they're
doing
and how it's affecting texans and talk
to people that are being affected
including the people that are on the
border
doing the work now let's talk about this
because today
democrats are expected to unveil a bill
that would expand the supreme court
to 13 justices uh let's take a listen to
joe biden's stance on this his stance
has flip-flopped a little bit take a
listen
my opinion of court packing when the
election is over i'm not a fan of
court packing you are open to expanding
the court
i'm open to considering what happens
from that point on at the end of the day
what do you think ends up happening here
and how
dangerous would this be well it's
it looks purely political i think most
of the members of the court have
expressed opinions on this
even ruth bader ginsburg said there's no
reason to to pack the court it looks
political
that body has been viewed as
non-political they're supposed to rule
on the law
there's been no reason given for why
they want to dissipate
the current impact of the court that
seems to be the direction we're going i
certainly hope
that we don't change things just for
political reasons so right now that's
what it looks like
and real quick you know obviously it
seems like the left would want to do
this to
help the left right but do you think
ultimately if this ended up happening
this could end up helping republicans
because we had congressman stubion
earlier this morning who said look
this could have an impact on the 2022
house races
oh there's no doubt i mean it may be one
of the main messages of
the races coming up and it may end up
backfiring which often happens
when you do something this extreme okay
ken paxton texas attorney general
thank you very much for joining us and
keep us updated on everything that's
going on in your state i know that
what's going on at the border
certainly impacts so many people down
there and they want to get some answers
and i know you do too
thank you have a great day